voilà monsieur bonsoir doyenne de
l'humanité jeanne calment s'est éteint
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 122 ans cette
femme que la mort semblait avoir négligé
avait enterré 17 président de la
république elle avait vécu l'apparition
de l'aviation à son adolescence et elle
avait tout juste 20 ans lorsque les
frères lumière ont inventé le
cinématographe pour trait signée patrice
volet l'adieu de jeanne l'arlésienne sa
vie entière elle est restée près du
rhône là où elle est né en 1875 une
jeunesse bourgeoise et bien vite le
mariage en 1898 il en naîtra une fille
la maison familiale se remarque encore
dans le centre d'arles ici jeanne a
traversé le siècle
elle en était la mémoire chaque
anniversaire était une fête un nouveau
record pour jeanne aveugle est de plus
en plus sourde au fil des années elle
avait toujours conservé sa vivacité
d'esprit son sens de la réplique face
aux innombrables questions des
journalistes à les jeunes disent nous
votre secret
depuis l'âge de 110 ans jeanne vivait en
arles dans cette maison de retraite
objet de toutes les attentions du
médecin du service entouré de ses
records de longévité être nés avant la
construction la tour eiffel lui valait
l'intérêt de toute la planète
d'argentine ou d'australie en fait du
monde entier il se déplaçait nombreux
journalistes photographes cinéastes pour
entourer jeanne calment chaque 21
février une popularité jamais démentie
jeanne s'était même lancé dans le cinéma
à 115 ans un petit rôle dans un film sur
van gogh
elle avait croisé le peintre dans sa
jeunesse une histoire qu'elle raconte
est volontiers déjà les plages bon
souvenir de lui il a été gracié et
impolie une doyenne toujours plus
médiatisé au fil des années le summum la
sortie de son cd 4 titres devant une
nuée de journalistes
jeanne avait accepté l'idée comme une
nouvelle expérience à 121,1 elle voulait
encore profiter de la vie
son médecin a toujours affirmé que rien
n'était fait contre sa volonté
sans doute même si jeanne calment était
depuis longtemps dépassé par son image
sur tous les écrans du monde
pour jacques chirac que cette
extraordinaire vieille dame était un peu
notre grand-mère à tous interrogé à
l'occasion de son 120e anniversaire sur
sa vision de l'avenir
jeanne calment avait alors répondu par
ces deux mou très bref son humour et sa
vitalité ont été salués par michel
vauzelle le maire d'arles qui a qualifié
la disparue de mémoire vivante de cette
ville reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
allemand nicosie jarre galian et didier
leduc
la maison de retraite du lac près
d'arles c'est ici que jeune calment a
fermé les yeux ce matin vers 10h après
avoir pris normalement son petit
déjeuner elle semble s'être éteinte tout
doucement le coeur a cessé de battre
c'est doyenne de l'humanité jeanne
calment vivait ici depuis 1985
l'administration de l'hôpital n'a pas
souhaité faire de déclaration
seul visiteur de marque le maire d'arles
michel vauzelle
on s'était fait à l'idée que j'aime
calme on ne nous quittera jamais chaque
année on se retrouvait autour d'elle sa
grande famille arlésiennes et elle était
notre grande soeur elle nous montrait le
chemin de la vie de la curiosité de de
l'appétit de vivre de la force de villon
en arles les drapeaux ont été mis en
berne comme ici au fronton de la mairie
la nouvelle de son décès a rapidement
parcouru les places et les rues je
trouve qu'elle prenne qu'il mène avec 6
me pour elle comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure un monsieur on a discuté
quant à des années 50 ses 112 ans déjà
pour fait que 325 peut-être espiègle
coquette vivent ceux qui ont connu
jeanne calment se souviennent tél yvonne
clergue qui participa à cette séance
photo et elle était ravie d'avoir
quelqu'un avec qui parler parce que pour
tout vous dire elle se sentait mieux
avec des gens qui venaient lui rendre
visite
plutôt qu'avec les personnes âgées qui
étaient autour d'elle elle n'avait rien
à voir avec les gens je me souviens qu
elle a pris cet éventail qui elle a fait
son petit regard comme ça qui lorsque
les photos des déterminée elle n'amuse à
elle nous a offert un verre de porto
le soir tombe sur la maison du lac que
104 pensionnaires habite encore rien n'a
changé
seul un petit supplément d'âme s'est
envolé
en direct de l'hôpital d'arles le
docteur catherine levraud qui a bien peu
me jeanne calment à qui elle a consacré
un noir de gériatrie il y a quatre ans
bonsoir docteur pourvu jeune allemand
était en quelque sorte médicalement le
prototype de la longévité humaine
oui tout à fait madame calment est une
personne qui pour un médecin est tout à
fait remarquable c'est à dire que tout
ce qu'on nous a appris et ça pour un
étudiant c'est agréable se retrouver
dans cette personne à la fois ses
qualités à la fois sa façon de vivre et
tout ça aboutissant à une personne tout
simplement toujours et plus que tout le
monde c'est quand même rassurant
alors est-ce que le secret si secret il
ya de sa longévité
ce n'est pas d'avoir rallié toute sa vie
une très bonne résistance physique mais
aussi une très très grande résistance
mentale
oui bien sûr nous avons affaire ici à
quelqu'un qu'il y a une famille tout à
fait remarquable de gens très solide et
qui ont vécu le très vieux c'est parents
son frère et elle même dans son enfance
a été élevé de façon tout à fait saine
et ensuite tout simplement elle s'est
retrouvée avec une vie très diverses
très sportive mais pas spécialement
fatigante car c'est une dame qui n'a pas
eu besoin de travailler pour gagner sa
vie est une vie tout à fait agréable
qu'elle a dit multiples reprises avoir
beaucoup apprécié et c'est vrai que
c'est quelqu'un qui est arrivé jusqu'à
un âge très avancé jusqu'à 110 ans en
infirmité sans maladie et elle a
commencé à délirer à partir de ce moment
là elle était même un petit peu coquette
en fait elle était très flatté d'être
devenu une vedette entre guillemets oui
madame calment et quelqu'un et c'est
rare parmi les personnes âgées qui
apprécient d'être montrées d'être
apprécié d'être admiré elle était très
sensible aux hommages qui lui était fait
elle était très sérieux dans sa
préparation
elle était en permanence convaincu qu'il
fallait faire bonne figure et même quand
elle était très fatiguée car quand
c'était une vieille dame elle faisait
son maximum pour se montrer sous son
meilleur jour
car elle pensait que c'était son rang
les fonds de voir merci beaucoup pour ce
témoignage en direct de l'hôpital
d'arles en 65 un notaire de cette ville
d'arles avait acheté en viager
l'appartement de jeunes tellement alors
âgé de 90 ans il est mort vingt mois
avant elle à l'âge de 77 ans après avoir
déboursé au total neuf cent vingt mille
francs
si l'âge atteint par jeanne calment plus
de 122 ans reste exceptionnel passé le
cap des 100 ans est en revanche de plus
en plus banal notamment en france où
l'on recensé environ 200 centenaire vers
1955 à 6000 aujourd'hui et on en prévoit
quelque cent cinquante mille ans l'an
2050 enquête france aux balles et jean
daniel flaysakier le jeune entre dans sa
centième année et son petit frère joseph
affiche 97 printemps
malgré les épreuves de la vie dont deux
ans au shit pour le jeune ils sont d'une
étonnante vitalité des gestes de la vie
quotidienne aux activités
intellectuelles en passant par les
promenades tous les jours le temps ne
semble pas avoir de prise sur les frères
classe il faut dire qu'ils ont sans
doute un petit secret oui et je vois pas
le désert
de plus en plus de personnes passe
aujourd'hui le cap des 90 ans
ils seront dix mille centenaire à l'aube
du xxième siècle et le travail s'en
moque l'hygiène de vie joue un rôle
parce qu'on ne voit pas quelle autre
facteur pourrait expliquer le fait
qu'actuellement nous gagnons trois mois
d'espérance de vie tous les ans le
réfrigérateur par exemple a fait
quasiment disparaître les cancers de
l'estomac dans notre pays on n'a plus
besoin grâce à lui de fumer ou de salina
viande pratique hautement cancérogènes
les aliments sont devenus beaucoup plus
sain les personnes âgées aujourd'hui mon
juin mais mieux les médicaments venons
pas prolonger la vie des personnes âgées
mais les empêcher de mourir précocément
de maladies facilement curable reste la
génétique on ne sait pas encore grand
chose de nos gènes du vieillissement
on sait cependant que les centenaires
ont un système de défense
particulièrement vaillant les personnes
qui vivent très longtemps ont un système
immunitaire très résistant solide et un
système immunitaire résistant
ça permet d'éviter des tas de
pathologies
des maladies infectieuses le cancer et
c'est peut être le dénominateur commun
des personnes qui vivent vraiment
longtemps grâce à une étude scientifique
appelée chronos
on en saura un peu plus sur la génétique
des centenaires dans quelques mois la
famille klein est très intéressé surtout
les trois petits frères et soeur de
joseph et eugène qui ont 87 83 et 81 ans
après la disparition de jeanne calment
le doyen de l'humanité est désormais un
américain d'origine danoise qui fêtera
ses cent quinze ans seulement
pourrait-on dire le 16 août prochain
sans transition comme disent mes
excellents confrères nous allons mettre
le cap vers athènes avec l'une des
principales épreuves du championnat du
monde d'athlétisme 400 m haies avec une
performance attendue du français
stéphane diagana vainqueur de sa
demi-finale tout financement direct
laurent frédéric bollée laurent c'est à
vous oui bonsoir bruno en direct
d'athènes effectivement pour vivre le
grand vent de cette foire est en tout
cas pour ce qui nous concerne nous
français la finale du 400 m haies
masculine alors vous le savez
effectivement stéphane diagana est
engagé dans cette finale et on nourrit
de très grands espoirs pour stéphane
diagana qui sera au couloir 6 stéphane
diagana recordman d'europe de la
spécialité qui a gagné sa demi-finale
dans sa meilleure performance mondiale
de l'année
autant dire que stéphane est tentante
mais il faudra qu'ils se méfient
notamment de l'américain que l'on vient
de voir brian bronson à la ligne 3 et de
l'italien fabrizio maury aligne 4 tout
de suite la composition très rapide de
cette finale
ligne 1 le sud-africain air perte en
le tchèque en 3 branson donc l'américain
qui est quand même le favori en quatre
murs et l'italien enfin qu'un russe
machine qu'on en dise diagana qui a donc
un petit peu le désavantage de voir ses
principaux rivaux derrière lui mais
après tout lors de sa demi finale
victorieuse
il était aussi aux cobras artistes et
fans diagana à l'antenne que vous voyez
à l'image au couloir 7 il y aura le
jamaïcain morgan au couloir 8 le zambien
samuel matete toujours redoutable dans
ces grands événements dans quelques
instants le départ de cette grande
finale
voilà ils sont partis pas d'autre n'a
pas une cause hier que tu es très rare
exactement quarante cinq mètres à
parcourir avant la première et hewitt
n'est d'ailleurs que c'est et 180 11,4
cm de haut
ces candidats qui manifestement a pris
un superbe départ puisqu'il est déjà
revenu sur son adversaire américain
morgan des pizzas ghana qui est un
spécialiste des départs canon après
évidemment la grande difficulté c'est de
tenir jusqu'au bout
on voit confier au couloir 8 samuel
matete n'est pas excellent tandis que
l'américain brandon évidemment n'est pas
mal du tout c'est quand même le favori
stéphane diagana l'antenne manifestement
il est en tête il doit déboucher en tête
lors de cette dernière ligne droite oui
stéphane est largement en tête
va-t-il tenir il reste environ 60 mètres
à parcourir la tension brian benson
fournissons effet en va-t-il rôle ya
stéphane piétonnier à main lui c'était
un bel avenir et stéphane diagana
peut-être devenir champion du monde
devenu sénégal champion du monde du 400
m c'est un véritable événement et
qu'est-ce qu'on est content je vous le
dis franchement pour stéphane diagana
qui est un type formidable un coureur
modèle solide intelligent lucides et ils
en portent aujourd'hui son premier grand
si stéphane diagana champion du monde il
y avait eu quelques déceptions le
concernant par le passé notamment une
médaille de bronze il ya deux ans
champion du monde eh bien aujourd'hui
c'est une éclatante revanche fort
stéphane diagana donc 28 ans champion du
monde du 400 m haies stéphane diagana
félicité par ses adversaires
ah je peux vous dire qu'il doit être
goûtées cependant avec une joie qui sera
toujours celui contenu car il est
sérieux de nature je vous le vivez
m'étais pas franchement doit ressentir
joie immense
c'est la consécration d'une carrière
parfois ils avaient déçu on lit en
faisait le reproche
eh bien cette fois ci s'il n'a pas déçu
au ralenti jusqu'à arriver bruno je
pense pour goûter ce moment exceptionnel
du sport français
c'est la première médaille de ces
championnats du monde et c'est une
médaille d'or ne boudons pas notre
plaisir des fans diagana donc qui aura
fait la course en tête manifestement et
qui devance l'américain branson qui
était pourtant annoncé comme le favori
son principal adversaire
je peux vous dire que c'est une verrine
véritable exploit pour ses fans dagana
que de devancer branson alors que le
sud-africain herbert ans manifestement
la 3e place aux rennais ligue
oui merci beaucoup de nous avoir fait
vivre donc on dirait que cette très très
très très bonne surprise pour le temps
de foncer
hier soir les deux épreuves reines
d'athlétisme comme on dit ont vu le
grand retour gagnant des sprinteurs
américains avec la victoire de maurice
greene dans le 100 m hommes et de marion
jones
dans le 100 m féminin six ans que
l'amérique attendait cela comment perd
toujours laurent frédéric bollée être
champion du monde du 100 m n'empêche pas
d'avoir des émotions
maurice greene dans les bras de son père
hier soir ce ne sont pas des larmes de
crocodile et pourtant pour une finale
c'est la loi de la jungle il faut
vaincre ou être battu ce qu aucun des
huit compétiteurs ne peut accepter green
au couloir 3 qui domine tout le monde et
notamment donovan bailey le champion
olympique en quelque sorte une passation
de pouvoir car green n'a que 23 ans
une nouvelle génération de sprinteurs
américains arrivent ambitieuse toujours
plus fort avec bien sûr l'inévitable
discours américain
je voudrais juste remercier dieu pour
m'avoir permis de révéler que j'ai fait
ici c'est enfin la victoire d'une bande
de copains qui à athènes ressemblent à
des statues antiques
honneur maintenant à marion jones et
sont financés lanceur de poids beau bébé
de 150 kg chez les femmes c'est la même
histoire non ce n'est pas mr les noter
qu'il gagne avec 89 davance c'est qu'il
ya un faux départ
non ce n'est pas l'ukrainienne but du
cndd qui gagne malgré des apparences
oui c'est bien marion jones un premier
type à 21 ans seulement
je pensais avoir gagné mais j'aimerais
inviter pas su maintenant je vais
célébrer ce filles marion jones
spécialiste du 100 m et aussi de la
longueur est les champions des états
unis de cette spécialité
les etats unis qui ont donc bien de la
chance avec maurice greene et marion
jones
la relève est assurée en france plus
d'un établissement sur trois accueillant
le public restaurants aux piscines ne
respectent pas toujours les
réglementations sur les normes d'hygiène
ou de sécurité
c'est le tout premier bilan de
l'opération pour des vacances sans nuage
une opération destinée à défendre les
consommateurs contre les arnaques de
l'été
au total 90 milles contrôles sont prévus
d'ici 30 sébastien guibert
salut courtois mais inspection
implacable hygiène sécurité information
les contrôleurs de la répression des
fraudes n'ont pas vraiment pris de
vacances durant ses trois premières
semaines de juillet et le bilan n'est
pas brillant sur 8500 établissements
contrôlés un sur trois a présenté des
irrégularités un sur dix a fait l'objet
d'un procès verbal trop tôt pour dire si
ces résultats sont pires ou meilleure
que l'été dernier mais les contrôleurs
ont relevé quelques graves infractions
et d'abord dans les restaurants
établissements les plus visibles
onze d'entre eux ont dû carrément fermé
leurs portes ce que les contrôleurs ont
parfois découvert avait vraiment de quoi
couper l'appétit des produits qualifiés
de frais sur la carte sortant en fait
tout droit du congélateur viandes et
poissons dont l'odeur révéler une
congélation plutôt douteux ou encore un
cuisinier stockant ses produits
d'entretien dans sa cuisine et ses
aliments dans son local à poubelles les
magasins d'alimentation ont été
également très surveillés plus de 7
tonnes de produits ont été détruits
comme par exemple une tonne et demie de
pommes de terre à moitié pourri en
partance pour des rayons de supermarchés
ou des surgelés qui malgré leur date
limite de fraîcheur fixée à janvier
dernier se trouvait toujours en chambre
froide prêt à l'achat reste enfin les
piscines dont les conditions de sécurité
sont de plus en plus attentivement
surveillées une piscine à d'ailleurs été
fermé les contrôleurs ont surtout
vérifier les fameuses gris d'aspiration
susceptible de blesser un baigneur ou le
plaquer au fond du bassin des fonds
parfois difficiles à discerner dans
l'eau était sale car mal ou pas filtré
du tout les vacanciers doivent donc
rester vigilant et c'est d'ailleurs
souvent sur plainte de leur part que les
contrôles sont effectués
protection des vacanciers suite avec eux
dans les alpes-maritimes ce dispositif
tout à fait unique de surveillance de la
propreté des eaux de baignade reportage
yasmina farber et richard chaud la
mission a été confiée à cet ancien
pilote de chasse sous-officier de
l'armée de l'air
sa reconversion en surveillant des eaux
de baignade et des zones de pollution à
25 ans à bord d'un rallye il scrute la
côte d'azur du 19 juin au 31 août un
regard d'aigle pour détecter du ciel les
déchets en surface
ça se voit comme le nez au milieu de la
figure
et c'est le courant ligure qui ramène
tout ça on le verrait très bien
l'opération ne survole coûte 200 mille
francs financés par le conseil général
des alpes-maritimes
tous les matins roger sillonnent 120 km
de côtes de théoule-sur-mer un manteau à
500 pieds 150 mètres d'altitude
il observe la méditerranée selon un
découpage dont il a le secret l'objectif
est de protéger les zones de baignade
de gagner ces protections rapprochées
des plages que les bateaux on peut pas
les envoyer
aulas
le commandant de bord guide une petite
armada de bateaux nettoyeurs avec
lesquels il est en liaison radio
o à peu près 100 m
le pélican célèbre embarcations pour les
habitués de la côte d'azur peut ainsi
mieux s'orienter pour avaler les déchets
qui polluent la méditerranée cet engin
mise au point il ya une vingtaine
d'années recueille les détritus et
aspire une partie des hydrocarbures
aujourd'hui la mère était relativement
propre seule une nappe de pétrole
rejetée par un bateau a attiré notre
regard en vol mais le littoral des
alpes-maritimes est plus exposé que
d'autres côtes françaises 4 près de 90 %
qui vient d'italie par le baril
ça vient ça vient de partout roger
pilote de chasse et tracker de déchets
prendra sa retraite après sept saisons
mais cette détection en vol unique au
monde devrait continuer l'été prochain
en cette période estivale vous êtes à
demi pardonnée
s'il n'est pas lui de près le journal
officiel sachez qu'un décret vient de
paraître aux jo modifiant une loi de 95
qui oblige quelques 8000 médecins
diplômés hors des 15 pays de l'union
européenne a passé un nouvel examen pour
pouvoir continuer à exercer en france
c'est une semi victoire pour le comité
des médecins à diplôme étranger qui ne
cachaient guère son inquiétude avant la
publication de ce décret reportage
florence book chaque jour depuis trois
ans le docteur mokaddem contrôler cette
console de scanner ou celle des
échographies il donne ses indications
aux manipulateurs radio interprète les
clichés établissent un diagnostic
algériens ils exercent dans les hôpitaux
français depuis près de 10 ans mais
depuis la loi veil de 1995 les médecins
à diplôme étranger doivent réussir un
concours aux critères d'inscription très
pointilleux trop pour le docteur
mokaddem il sera donc bientôt remercier
où il travaille depuis dix ans
en tant que radio locke reconnu
et pratiquant la médecine la radiologie
comme tout radiologues et d'un coup on
n'y voit rien
rien ne permette sein n'ont pas fait
d'études au centre hospitalier de meaux
comme dans presque tous les petits
hôpitaux de province
un médecin sur trois est étranger et
très peu sont admis à passer le concours
d'où l'inquiétude des chefs de service
si les médecins du cône étrangers soirée
vers les hôpitaux c'est qu'en fait il
manquait deux médecins français au sein
des équipes
donc s'il y en a un nombre important et
qui doit partir le problème se reposera
pour okah fonctionné qu'une jument les
différents services
cette mise en application de la
législation baboo tir dans bon nombre
d'établissements y compris celui ci si
rien ne change par ailleurs à des
difficultés de fonctionnement extrêmes
et immédiats notamment dans les secteurs
de réanimation d'image pour ne citer que
les principaux ce problème crucial pour
les petits hôpitaux généraux touche
également des services hospitaliers de
pointe dans de grands hôpitaux de
l'assistance publique
ainsi celui de réanimation néo
pédiatrique de l'hôpital antoine béclère
à clamart
car les médecins à diplôme français
s'oriente de moins en moins vers une
spécialité pédiatrique encore moins vers
la néonatologie jugeait mal payés et
trop pénible les prématurés doivent être
surveillés 24 heures sur 24
ici sur trente médecins 12 oh des
diplômes étrangers
on peut admettre éventuellement que la
formation initiale de ces médecins ne
soit pas tout à fait au niveau de la
formation du diplôme français
le problème c'est que ces médecins se
sont spécialisés d'abord en pédiatrie et
au sein de la pédiatrie en néonatologie
et que dans ce cadre là ils ont acquis
une compétence j'ai tout à fait
excellentes de vrais médecins donc qui
plus est très souvent naturalisés ils
sont français un cursus étrangers
bientôt interdits de travail au liban
cinq membres présumés du mouvement
hezbollah pro iranien ont été tués ce
matin par l'explosion d'une bombe placée
au bord d'une route paraître mandeau
israéliens hors de la zone occupée par
l'état hébreu au liban sud
selon plusieurs témoignages un avion de
reconnaissance israélien sans pilote
survolé ce secteur leur discrétion un
attentat qui survient après de violents
affrontements cette nuit entre les
combattants du hezbollah et un commando
israélien et il portait alors qu'israël
l olp se rejettent toujours mutuellement
la responsabilité directe ou indirecte
de l'attentât qui a fait 15 morts
mercredi sur un marché dit rusal m
l'activité diplomatique s'intensifie
afin de sauver ce qui reste du processus
de paix au proche orient sur place pour
france 2 charles enderlin
premier diplomate à se mesurer à la
crise l'espagnol miguel angel moratinos
émissaires européens au proche-orient ce
matin yasser arafat lui a demandé
d'intervenir auprès du premier ministre
israélien pour lever au moins en partie
le bouclage des territoires palestiniens
non lui répondre à monsieur netanyahou
en début d'après-midi il n'en est pas
question
sans arrestations en masse de militants
islamistes à gaza et en cisjordanie le
premier ministre croit que ces nouvelles
attaques nouvelle bombe explose dans les
jours qui viennent
ça serait une catastrophe pour nous tous
c'est pour cela que les mesures qu'il a
prises et dont la volonté d'éviter
qu'une nouvelle bande puis se détaillait
faire dérailler définitivement le
processus dont ils nous craignent elles
explosent régionales non je ne crois pas
je crois qu'on est dans une moments les
plus difficiles du processus
mais je crois qu'il ya dans tous les
endroits de la région de jambi politique
avec une vision historique
parmi ces leaders politiques le roi
hussein de jordanie chekili assez rare à
pâte est allé passer la soirée le
président palestinien ne veut pas céder
aux exigences israéliennes
il estime qu'une vague d'arrestations
d'islamistes le rendrait encore plus
impopulaire chez les palestiniens
au moment où les autorités israéliennes
poursuivent la destruction de maisons
construites sans permis à jérusalem est
à téhéran mohammad khatami est devenu
officiellement le cinquième chef de
l'exécutif de la république islamique
d'iran depuis la révolution de 79 en
prêtant serment ce matin devant le
parlement
vainqueur au mois de mai de l'élection
présidentielle grâce essentiellement aux
voix des femmes et des jeunes
ce religieux incarne l'ale réformatrice
et libérale au sein du clergé iranien
bientôt l'heure de la relève pour les
malheureux occupants de la station mir
deux cosmonautes russes vont en effet
décoller demain à de baïkonour pour
venir réparer les dégâts occasionnés à
la suite d'une collision fin juin entre
cette station orbitale russe et un
vaisseau ravitailleur précision au mieux
elles de bonnes ans pour rejoindre leurs
beats de mire à 400 km de la terre les
cosmonautes vont mettre 48 heures dans
la soirée du 7 août le sas entre soyouz
émir s'ouvrir à l'équipage actuellement
dans la station deux russes et un
américain
or alors une semaine pour établir avec
les deux arrivants un bilan complet de
l'état de la station le 25 juin dernier
une collision avec un cargo de
ravitaillement avait endommagé la
paroisse est l'un des panneaux solaires
du module spectre prévand la station de
60 % de son énergie électrique
le 14 août si les y ai fait la zone
qu'ils reviendront sur terre après avoir
vécu un incendie des panneaux
électriques et informatiques
une collision et même des problèmes
cardiaques
pour le commandant de bord l'américain
restera lui en orbite pendant les
réparations
six jours plus tard les choses sérieuses
commenceront les cosmonautes
s'équiperont de scaphandres identique à
celui ci prévue normalement pour des
sorties dans l'espace mais ils
interviendront à l'intérieur dans ces
quelques mètres cubes du module
dépressurisé après l'accident
pendant les réparations michael folle se
placera aux commandes du soyouz en cas
de retour précipité l'opération devrait
durer cinq heures pour tenter ce
qu'elles ont déjà réussi à
l'entraînement piscine le branchement
d'une dizaine de câbles complètement
inaccessible
en fait le niveau de difficulté de cette
opération est assez bas le travail n'est
pas très difficile mais notre
responsabilité est grande
les deux russes reprendront leurs
scaphandres le 3 septembre pour une
sortie dans l'espace cette fois ils
devront inspecter la paroisse de mire
percer sur trois centimètres carrés mais
le colmatage ne devrait pas commencer
avant ses vrilles et 1998 dans la grande
série un sou est un sou l'armée
française appelée à faire des économies
drastiques comme l'on dit en revanche un
certain nombre de ses propriétés dont la
citadelle de bonifacio
une opération qui ne s'annonce pas
simple comme on constaté sur place
jacques cardoze et bruno livertout à
l'extrême sud de la corse au bout des
falaises en prolongement de la ville
hôte une citadelle à vendre enfin plus
tout à fait un site à l'aide de mots
lors de bonifacio c'est à sur une
superficie de 35 millimètres carrés
depuis le début de l'été ce n'est plus
qu'aux équipes de télévision que
l'adjudant de l'aisne ce fait visiter
les trente cinq mille mètres carrés de
terrain la vente de ce domaine unique
est en effet suspendu jusqu'à l'automne
le temps pour les élus corses de
convaincre l'état de payer en état un
investissement de 100 millions de francs
100 millions de francs c'est encore
réalisable pour une collectivité comme
la corse entière
mais après celle fonctionnement et la
halle fonctionnement ne peut plus
dépendre de la seule corse des seules
institutions corse et encore moins de
bonifacio
la mise à prix du terrain avait été
fixée à 8 millions de francs sa
rénovation estimés à 50 millions de
francs + les frais de fonctionnement
malgré son mauvais état plusieurs
acquéreurs corse ou non s'étaient
manifestés mais sous la pression des
tendances nationalistes
il n'est désormais plus question de
céder la totalité du domaine uniquement
au secteur privé reste une troisième
solution
je pense que c'est par un ensemble à la
fois peut-être un hôtel de bonne qualité
peut être des logements sociaux
peut-être des bâtiments administratifs
peut être d
locaux de dieu de différentes natures
qu'on peut trouver
il n'y aura pas en somme un seul projet
il y aura un ensemble de projets qui
feront un quartier nouveau de bonnes
isation l'appel est lancé
rendez vous à l'automne reste le plus
important trouvèrent une idée adapté au
site
or jusqu'à présent toutes ont échoué
école de pilotes d'hélicoptères
université d'été ou école d'hôtellerie
dans notre série cultivons notre jardin
ce petit détour par chaumont sur loire
qui organise autour de son château et
pour la sixième année consécutive un
festival des jardins thème cette année
que d'eau que d'eau pour reprendre
l'expression du toujours regretté mme
hackmann
reportage en espère un natel quelles
fleurs des champs et fontaine de bambou
mû par de minces filets d'eau sont
insolites qui suscite le regard toujours
en alerte dans ce jardin baignée de
soleil
un peu plus loin un espace très
construit les plantes entourée d'eau
lisse et s'agitent au bord de la noyade
du décor de théâtre c'est pas des
oeuvres d'art c'est vraiment des vrais
jardin et c'est les gens qui viennent
d'ailleurs où il ya plein de gens qui
prennent toujours des notes comme ça
qu'ils écrivent pour piquer les idées on
en interne a découvert un peu ce thème
et c'est vrai que ils viennent nous voir
l'année d'après avec les photos de ce
qu'ils ont réalisé réussies ou ratées
mais c'est ça qui passe si c'est quelque
chose de très modeste et très proche des
gens mieux l'expérience lieu
d'expérience à portée de tous c'est pas
si compliqué à chaumont-sur-loire tous
les jardins sont l'oeuvre de paysagistes
ou d'architecte bien souvent épaulés par
un sculpteur ou un plasticien qui
deviennent polar ou pour la botanique
le public a l'air d'aimer ça y est je
chante mètres carrés de jardin
pourquoi on fait grand chose ils vont
pas prendre un jardin ils vont prendre
un blog qui vont prendre une micro scène
c'est à dire une association de deux
plantes de deux couleurs
quand on est passionné de jardins que
l'on rencontre dans les landes journée
qu'on rencontre une plan deux trois
quatre plantes
on est heureux il ya aussi les
professionnels toujours à la quête du
petit truc chez nous c'est un légume
oublié
on est plusieurs à feignies on vient ici
pour photographier ce jardin pour
promouvoir pour donner des idées à nos
étudiants quelques peintres aussi
inspiré par cette nature généreuse se
protéger par exemple fouillis
inextricable de choux courges et des
tomates dont l'artiste isole joliment
ces quelques fleurs vous propose
maintenant de revenir sur la très très
bonne surprise venue tout à l'heure vous
l'avez vécu en direct sur france 2 des
championnats du monde d'athlétisme
d'athènes la médaille d'or de stéphane
diagana dans le 400 m haies c'était
françois vraiment à cet instant précis
le seul qui sait c'est lui
stéphane diagana est le seul à savoir ce
qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut faire
c'est partir vite car samuel matete à sa
droite et brian branson derrière lui ne
sont pas des spécialistes du départ
canon diagana lui fit et son départ et
canon il remonte un à un tous ses
adversaires
le zambien et l'américain sont les
favoris mais diagana sait qu'il peut les
battre
à condition de tenir dans la dernière
ligne droite
et diagana tient à 28 ans il offre sa
première médaille à la france
il s'offre sa première médaille d'or à
lui champion du monde du 400 m haies
maintenant il sait
une fois qu'on est dans les blocs on est
tous les uns contre les autres on sait
combien c'est dur
le 400 m haies est particulièrement on
sait que c'est difficile on a beaucoup
de respect mutuel et samuel était
vraiment content pour moi il m'avait dit
que c'était pas trop s'en aller qu'ils
avaient ouvert 2 et samuel et brian
branson également la lire ici et pour
apprennent à les galères comme comme
j'ai eu l'année dernière balle je pense
que ça ce que ça représente pour moi et
je pensais sincèrement 97 bougies
aujourd'hui pour queen mum comme on
surnommait affectueusement les
britanniques la reine mère elizabeth qui
a su préserver l'admiration de ses
sujets malgré malgré la succession de
scandales qui ont miné l'image de la
famille royale
sur ces images du monde le point de vue
de tirer puis les anglais la surnomme
avec affection et respect
queen mum est aujourd'hui à londres
c'est son jour la reine mère souffle
c'est 97 bush
bien sûr au fil des ans sa démarche est
fait plus hésitante
ces sorties plus rares mais celle qui
fut reine de 37 à 50 2 demeure la plus
populaire au sein de la famille royale
et chaque année ces sujets lui souhaite
un bon anniversaire
c'est l'anniversaire de la reine mère
super quand on la regarde on se demande
pourquoi le reste de la famille n'est
pas comme elle c'est sans doute là que
réside le secret d'une popularité jamais
démentie
la reine mère elle n'a jamais fait la
une de la presse à scandale une belle
histoire pour terminer celle d'un groupe
d'enfants sicilien déshérités qui lors
d'une excursion à trouver un
portefeuille contenant plus de 30 mille
francs en billets ses enfants contactés
eux mêmes le propriétaire du
portefeuille qui les a remerciés en leur
offrant une crème glace - mesquine leur
musicalité a annoncé l'organisation
d'une grande fête dernier journal vers
12h45 en compagnie de laurence ostolaza
demain à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités rémy
range recevra le critique gastronomique
jean luc petitrenaud
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet avec à mardi lourd et orageux à
trésors vous retrouverez antoine cormery
quant à moi j'aurais plaisir de vous
retrouver à 20 heures après avoir eu le
privilège de vous souhaiter une bonne
nuit du 4 août très très bonne soirée
merci
tapie